this is the statement from art rooney ii
president of the pittsburgh steelers i
could just read it off the screen ben
rothsberger and i met yesterday morning
and we had a productive meeting we were
able to discuss a lot of things that
relate to where we are and where we want
to go
ben assured me that he is committed to
coming back to help us win as opposed to
coming back to help us lose and i told
ben that we would like to have him back
to help us win a championship here's the
most important part shireen
we both understand the next step is to
work out ben's contract situation said
it before saying it again saying it
right now it should take minutes to work
out his contract if they're going to
give him his full 19 million dollars
this is not difficult to do i can figure
it out that shows you how easy it is to
do it and with every minute that goes by
without that contract done
i think it's
it's fair to wonder are the steelers
going to try to squeeze him to take less
than 19 million this year shireen
oh i absolutely think that's the case
mike when you look at their cap
situation and what poor shape they're in
right now i have no doubt that's going
to be the case and how long this drags
out i think
is the the ultimate question here
because i do think ben roethlisberger
returns as a steelers quarterback for
this season as
sims said this morning on your show mike
i just don't see a better option for
them at this point they can go content
now i what it's content mean i think
they contend for the division title i
don't think they contend for a super
bowl i don't think they're as good as
the kansas city chiefs even if ben comes
back especially when you consider that
cap situation all the free agents they
have mike i just don't see this as a
team that's going to contend for super
bowl but it buys them another year and
as some said band-aid type thing to
apply for for a year uh it gives them
their best chance to have another
winning record which they've done every
year since 2003 or non-losing records
since 2003 gives them a chance to do
that go back to the playoffs but i just
don't see this as a as a team in
contention mike with or without ben
roethlisberger
i still think it's a mistake and i still
think both sides are going to live to
regret this in november or december and
they're going to say we just shouldn't
have done it that's my prediction i
could end up on freezing cold takes with
that quote at some point down the road i
just think it makes more sense if you
don't reasonably believe you're going to
win the super bowl it makes more sense
to just move on now and one of the
things sims and i discussed today we are
smack dab in that period of the
offseason where confidence runs a muck
in the various team facilities you're
far enough removed from what happened
last season and you're deep enough into
your thoughts of well if we just do this
if we just do this if we just do that
we're going to win the super bowl i
think it's easy to get caught up in the
sense of delusion that you can make the
climb all the way up to the top of the
stack and
i just don't think that that's realistic
and i really do think both sides would
be better off moving on
i think both sides are concerned about
how the fan base will react this is
going to be an awkward parting of the
ways
and maybe the only
non-awkward way to do it or the least
awkward way to do it is to let everyone
know
that this
is it a year from now there may be some
fans that say let's do it again see
that's the problem shireen if they get
to the afc championship this year
won't there be
a sense a desire
an argument to be made that they should
run it back one more time and keep doing
that until you have that year where you
do regret it anything other than winning
the super bowl is going to create that
same sense of well let's give it one
more shot let's give it one more shot
let's give it one more shot and i think
the long-term best interest of the team
are best served by saying it's over it's
done let's move on that's my opinion
steelers fans be very happy i'm not
making those decisions but if if i had
stumbled into the right family
relationship where i'm i'm pulling the
levers and i'm pressing the buttons the
button i'd press is eject on ben
roethlisberger because it's time to move
on and we're not winning the super bowl
this year
okay i have a question for you mike so i
understand this you say both sides are
going to end up regretting this so what
does that mean does that mean they go
eight and eight does that mean they make
the playoffs and lose in the first round
like what does regret mean because who
would you have them
play at quarterback if you're hitting
the eject button what you do you have a
complete reset here for the organization
so explain to me what regret means at
the end of the year
well to me regret means them saying to
themselves i wish we wouldn't have done
it and there are various ways that can
manifest itself he could get hurt again
if if what happened two years ago
happens this year and he exits by the
end of september with a knee with a hip
with a back with a something as his body
gets closer and closer to its physical
expiration date they're going to regret
it they're going to say oh god we're
giving this guy 19 million dollars and
we got two games out of him or three
games out of him or whatever the case
may be he's got the knee injuries and we
still don't know what's wrong with the
knees either they lied again on the
injury report because remember they got
busted last year for lying on the injury
report and concealing the elbow problem
either they lied about it last year with
his knees or he has knee issues and just
didn't get any treatment on his knees
because there's nothing they can do
about the knees so you don't have to
disclose him as having a knee injury if
you're not doing any you know mr miyagi
thing to try to make the knees better if
he just has arthritis well guess what if
that's the case it ain't getting any
better it's not going to be better when
everyone is a year older so yeah i think
they're either what what
whatever they think they're going to be
and i think continuing this relationship
is kind of a subtle message that they
think they can be damn good here it is
in the statement i told ben that we
would like to have him back to help us
win
a championship that's the bar not afc
north championship a championship so
regret means they're going to get to a
point
thanksgiving maybe sooner maybe later
where they say crap we ain't going to
win a championship we'd have been better
off starting down the path of seeing
what we have in mason rudolph seeing
what we have in dwayne haskins drafting
someone trading up doing something to
begin this post ben roethlisberger
existence because now what's going to
happen is they're not going to win a
championship they're going to have to do
it next year
but here's the thing mike if say he
exits week two like he did two years ago
hey we're expecting full stadiums at
that point the stadium is full which i
understand steelers fans always come out
maybe it's full if they start mason
rudolph maybe it's full if they start
dwayne haskins who knows maybe it's for
whoever they start at quarterback but i
do know it will be full if ben
roethlisberger is there week one whether
he exits week two or week ten or week
whatever it is he the stadium is going
to be full and those steelers fans are
going to be excited that ben
roethlisberger has come back for one
more year they're going to sell a lot of
jerseys they're going to do all those
things and they're going to make some
money off of this but
i i get it and and i understand you know
maybe it is time to look at dwayne
haskins or look at mason rudolph and
start that hard reset button on a team
that's not going to be able to go out
and get a big name quarterback to help
this franchise it's probably going to
lose bud dupree and some of those other
free agents that they have but i know
they're looking at hey we were 11-0 to
start the season and as you said mike
you get far enough away from that season
you forget how december ended you forget
those five interceptions that been
through in december and you say hey we
can get back to that point where we were
11-0 with ben
you've touched on what i am now going to
refer to as the nfl's version of the big
lie and that is that when they say the
goal is to win a championship the truth
is the goal is to make wait for it
as much money as they possibly can and
in order to make as much money as they
possibly can they have to say not
we're going to try to bring ben back and
make as much money as we possibly can
they have to say we're going to try to
win a championship
if you truly determine whether or not
you're successful based on winning a
championship you are pissed off every
year sorry london the patriots fail more
than two-thirds of the time one of the
best teams we've ever seen still a
failure more than two-thirds of the time
because they've only won six
championships in the last 20 years so
this very well may be this may vary
let's just fill the stadium let's make
everybody happy let's not upset the
apple cart this is our first year
post pandemic we got a lot of salty fans
who resent the fact that they weren't
able to come last year let's just give
them one more year of ben roethlisberger
let's give them what they want they get
to see ben for one more year wouldn't it
be a shame if in his last year there
were no fans that got to see him so
let's let them see ben for one more year
and then we'll deal with it next year
that may be the truth
but they ain't going to put that in the
statement sharing
no absolutely they're not mike and
frankly the quarterback market maybe
it's better next year maybe the free
agent markets better maybe they have a
higher draft pick because they did have
regrets and it didn't work out like they
thought it would work out and they have
a horrible season and it's been a long
time since pittsburgh's had a horrible
season but just say they have a horrible
season they'll have a chance to draft
the top quarterback or one of the top
quarterbacks next year so maybe it works
better for them for the future just
playing it out and seeing what happens
with ben this year mike and having a
full stadium and having people excited
to start the season to see what the
students can do one last time perhaps
with big ben
one thing they definitely should not do
is wait 20 years between ben
roethlisberger and next franchise
quarterback terry bradshaw retired after
the 83 season a year in which they
passed on dan marino because they didn't
want to have an awkward transition from
mourinho or from terry bradshaw to
mourinho 21 years later they used the
11th overall pick on ben roethlisberger
i would not wait as long to get your
next franchise quarterback if i'm the
steelers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports